what type of temperament and skills does
producer or line producer need to have
patience a lot of patience yeah it's
that and there's really people
management skills and oddly enough it's
just being able to multitask and manage
a large group of people who are all
different personalities you know your
wardrobe and your makeup are usually the
more kind of fashionable type people
where in your genie guys are a little
more you know a little more rough you
know they're like the blue-collar
workers if you will yeah no offense I'll
just give it to me straight
yeah these guys are you know there's
hang up lice or they're carrying heavy
equipment and they're driving the trucks
and it's you know so it just takes the
people who are just really driven to
come out here and work 12 13 hours a day
and get it done so no matter that the
department it's about the the ability of
people to really come here and have a
great personality and positive attitude
to work 12 14 hour days and get the job
done so for me when I actually hire
anyone from the PA to the grip to the
capper to whatever the department I
usually base it off their personality
and the type of energy that they bring
in the interview because to me anyone
can learn a skill set anyone can really
you know build that resume evacuates and
but they have a bad attitude or negative
energy or and their morale is not very
high like I won't hire them I don't care
who they are because I want my success
to be ran at that highest level so when
the problems always happen on set so if
something happens almost some people a
team that's going to say that we got to
we know how to get around this and and
and keep it and keep the ball rolling
it sounds like in some sense you have to
be a chameleon to deal with different
personalities and maybe they're not bad
personalities but they just receive
information in different ways yeah
absolutely
and I think I was smart in the way I
went about transit you know learning
about producing is when I was younger I
worked for a production company but when
I moved to I just focused on acting and
before I've shot my first film I spent a
year working production that called up
all my friends that worked it and said
hey can I come work in your department
so I for myself I worked like in
catering crafty I did work in for my
gross grip which I would never do again
but much respect to those guys I take
everything we have worked every
department cuz I wanted to understand
the fundamentals of how about Department
worked and I thought I thought it's a
producer that one would be be great for
me and to be able to communicate
properly with those guys to no one
understand the terminology to know what
they need it to know what they didn't
need it when their life we want this but
you really don't need it you want it and
we can't afford it or yeah we can't
afford it sounds like a lot of - what
you do is to assure people that things
are gonna be fine and then you fix it
behind the scenes yes thank you come
yeah we never want to the production
team or the crew to really know what
we're dealing with behind the scenes you
know so for example we had something
happened the other day which was we
couldn't keep under wraps because an
actor just enjoy what sure sure so much
sounds like that happens is you can't
keep it on their ass but right we always
have a solution and we always have a
anybody it's a way you deal with when
you're worried that you're in charge
this right man appreciate it
easy call c-47s for whatever reasons to
me they're clothespins clothespins yeah
I remember drawing my laundry I forgot
why they a lot of the terminology is
interesting because it comes from like
that when they were making movies in the
20s and 30s they just came up with
random names for things like this yeah
but yeah so it it is we want to keep
everything kind of you know find the
scenes and always have a plan a B and C
and there's something goes wrong we
resolve and that's really the biggest
job as a producer is problem solving
on the fly you know and making sure that
things keep moving
you